i know you all are so excited for
hogwarts legacy but i
also know you have some concerns in
today's video we're going to talk all
about the five biggest concerns i have
for hogwarts legacy and how avalanche
can avoid them
people of the international retro
recontour here if we're meeting for the
first time
you guys know i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream
over on twitch pretty soon i'm gonna be
doing a playthrough over there on the
twitch channel guys of all the harry
potter video games at least all that i
can
find anyway head on over there and make
sure you follow the stream though so you
won't miss
any of those updates now i'm a pretty
optimistic person and if you haven't
been able to tell from my other videos
on the channel here i am pretty
hyped for hogwarts legacy this game
seems to be in a style that harry potter
fans have wanted
for years that being said there are
definitely some concerns with the game
i'm sure you have many as well in fact
i've read a bunch of your concerns
there's enough negativity in our world
already on a day-to-day basis so instead
of just leaving it with a concern i'm
gonna try and put a positive spin on
each of these and say how i think
avalanche can actually turn these
concerns
into a positive look make no mistake the
hype for this game is through the roof i
know because so many of you guys comment
on these videos to let me know how
pumped you are
and of course i share in your enthusiasm
for this game
the trailer has been viewed more than 15
million
times there's a subreddit with new hopes
and ideas posted daily
and speaking of the trailer while we
wait for a new one or even just new
screenshots what would you guys like
playing during these videos of mine
should we just stick with the trailer
again and again screenshots maybe
perhaps me just talking to the camera
let me know what you guys think because
i am totally down to spice it up and
switch things up a bit
hopefully we'll get new info soon anyway
and we can just show that but until then
i'm curious to see what you all think so
let me know in the comments
at this point there are just so many
unknowns with the game we don't really
have much to go off of at this point
there's really three big pieces of media
or pr
i guess you could say that we have so
far and that is number one the official
faq on the website the trailer itself
as well as a playstation blog post as
die hard fans of the wizarding world i
think it's important we find ways to
keep the hype remain constructive with
our suggestions but to also try our best
to keep
expectations in check i don't want us to
be set up for a situation where we won't
accept anything less than a perfect game
with every single detail we've always
wanted because as much as i love seeing
the ideas you all have
each and every week on all these videos
there's just no way they're gonna be
able to fit all of that into this game
there's
just no way in developing any game there
are compromises that must be made and i
do think most of you out there
realize this now i'm not saying you
shouldn't wish for the moon if you want
to hope for a fully explorable hogwarts
with branching narrative paths
best-in-class gameplay quidditch diagon
alley young double door and a story with
side quests that rival the witcher
then sure go for it i have plenty of
hopes myself heck i made a whole video
about it but at the same time i think we
need to be careful
not to set ourselves up for
disappointment it's important to
remember avalanche is taking on a
massive task trying to please millions
of fans in what is a very ambitious
project for them
i don't think it's a knock on avalanche
for me to say they just don't have much
experience in this genre they do have
plenty of experience working with other
big time franchises like they do with
the disney infinity series but
not specifically open world action rpgs
in order for them to pull this off here
are my five biggest concerns and what i
think they can do to make it a positive
and not a negative number one a poor
story
look we open every video on the channel
here by saying i'm a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell story is
really important to me in games
but even more so than the story within
the game itself the story that we tell
ourselves and the story around
our lives how the game changes us is
equally important but as for hogwarts
legacy any game drawing huge inspiration
from a book series obviously needs to
make the story a top priority
now there's kind of pros and cons with
this here first of all there's an
enormous
amount of source material to pull from
here ultimately though i think the key
to this game's success will be how
capable avalanche is of
balancing their own original material
but also staying true to the canon and
this is just no easy task here if they
go
too much on the side of their own stuff
then long time fans could feel the game
as a disservice to the original works
and if they play it too safe sticking to
what we already know about the wizarding
world then players will say it's
repetitive and not unique
the devs are certainly saying all the
right things so far
in adrian rob's playstation blog post he
said the following
quote i like to say that what we are
giving fans is something familiar
in a way they have never seen that quote
alone
tells me they understand the balancing
act they've been tasked with
in order for hogwarts legacy to have a
strong original story that's steeped in
wizarding lore they'll need
strong supporting characters the
original series had a huge cast of
strong supporting characters that became
just as beloved as harry potter himself
in some cases even more so than harry
it's also crucial for there to be a
strong antagonistic
force and hopefully there's room for
morally gray characters as well
it's important for the main conflict to
carry significance and weight but
hopefully it's not just another save the
world and defeat the dark wizard story
we've already seen play out in the books
number two
boring or repetitive spell casting as
charming as some of the original harry
potter video games were most of them
suffer from what the internet likes to
refer to as
call of potter if you're not familiar
with that term
essentially many of the spell battles
turned into third person
shooting games that grow quickly
repetitive and ultimately feel like just
another generic shooting game
the wii version of order of the phoenix
managed to switch this up somewhat by
taking advantage of the wii motion
controls
for avalanche to avoid this pitfall with
hogwarts legacy they'll need to start by
having a variety of different spells in
the game
stupefy and flupindo shouldn't be the
end-all be-all
all the time it's okay for some battles
to be fast and aggressive yet there
should also be scenarios where a more
slow-paced precision approach can work
with all the magical possibilities in
this world
stealth should be an option during
certain gameplay situations as well
and maybe most importantly the spell
itself needs to matter
let us do the work and in-game research
to figure out which spells work
best against various types of enemies
number three
replayability first off hogwarts legacy
is an
open world action rpg not
an mmo i know harry potter fans want an
mmo set
in the wizarding world but that is not
what this game is intended to be
so we can't go in expecting near
unlimited replay value with years and
years of updates ahead
that being said i do think there are
plenty of steps avalanche can take to
ensure this is an experience and a world
we want to get lost in for
hours on end hogwarts needs to feel
alive and vibrant
rich with specific characters we can get
to know and not packed with too many
generic npcs or standard character
models that we see over and over again
the side quests need to be expansive and
hopefully story driven
try and keep the basic fetch quests to a
minimum maybe most importantly of all
hogwarts needs to feel like a fully
fleshed out character all on its own
this is where avalanche can really let
their attention to detail
of the canon shine considering we
already know so much about hogwarts
and yet while harry potter games
attempted it in the past we've never
been able to freely explore
so many of the iconic locations and
secret passages we know from the books
hopefully the castle is just massive and
a place we can truly get lost in
exploring at our leisure
packing a bunch of epic side quests with
moral choices and i think we'll have a
ton
of replay value number four meaningless
choices
speaking of the moral choices we already
know there's going to be a morality
system
in place for hogwarts legacy but these
can be tricky to pull off
having choice in a game certainly isn't
a novel idea like it once was and to
that point
gamers have come to expect much more
than when morality systems first started
becoming a trend they'll need to make
sure our choices
aren't meaningless they'll need to have
choices with both short-term and
long-term repercussions
ultimately we know will likely end up as
light or dark but the paths need to feel
demonstrably different
this too will help with the replay value
number five
invasive microtransactions in 2020
nothing can ruin a game faster than
microtransactions that come off as
invasive or exploitative
of players wb games should absolutely
know all about avoiding this when you
look back at what happened with middle
earth shadow of war this was i think in
2018.
the loot boxes in shadow of war were so
poorly received that the developer
monolith ended up
convincing wb to have them completely
removed from the game
here's a quote from monolith they said
quote in order to fully restore the core
promise of the nemesis system
will be permanently removing gold war
chests and the market from
shadow of war this means the option to
purchase gold with
real world money and the ability to gain
org followers from war chests will be
removed there will be a specific amount
of time given for players to utilize
their unused gold
if players have unused gold by the end
of the time allotted to spend it any
remaining gold will be converted to
in-game
items close quote look to be honest i
actually think they could pull off
special skins or maybe customizable
broom stuff like that
but at the end of the day i'd much
rather they pack all of that into the
main game and maybe go the story dlc
route if they really want to keep
players engaged for even longer
and have that possibility of an
additional revenue stream down the line
i certainly have high hopes for hogwarts
legacy and i know this is a passion
project for the team at
avalanche it's a huge opportunity for
them
to create something truly special as
always thank you guys so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon